avant de répondre à vos questions
mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs avant de livrer ma vérité
en toute transparence
je souhaiterais quand même remettre les
gens les enjeux au centre du village si
j'ose dire sans me dérober et sont
invités aucune question
je suis sous serment je l'ai rappelé et
vous le savez
il y a eu sans doute sans doute des
erreurs partagées dans cette affaire
et je vous ferai part au fur et à mesure
des griefs que j'ai moi-même contre les
uns et les autres les politiques
l'administration
mais contrairement à d'autres je ne suis
pas venu ici pour défendre une carrière
je ne suis pas venu ici
pour faire de la communication
je ne suis pas venu ici pour me
justifier comme ce justifierait un
coupable parce que je ne suis coupable
de rien d'un point de vue pénal je le
répète
le fond est le plus grave à mes yeux
c'est ce que je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui
et j'ai des griefs contre elle
l'on s'attaque à une ministre
de la République
en vérité on s'attaque un gouvernement
au mépris de la vérité parfois
non je le dis
Marlène Schiappa n'est pas mon ami elle
n'a pas été hier et elle le sera encore
moins demain
mais non Marlène Schiappa
n'écoutable ni de détournement d'argent
ni dans quelconque copinage je le
précise